Gregg from Brooklyn New York wrote in
and he said I could I would like to hear
President Donald Trump read the opening
crawl of Star Wars
there goes Star Wars it's all right cuz
space force is coming huge space force
gonna be unbelievable all the guys in
space fighting for America America first
space voice first unbelievable all right
Donald Trump's gonna read the Star Wars
Kroc we get that crawled up in there and
going it's a period of civil war okay a
lot of good people on both sides rebel
spaceships striking from a hidden base
losers said have won their first victory
against the evil Galactic Empire but I
think a big Empire wave is coming okay
during the battle rebel spies managed to
steal secret plants to the Empire's
ultimate weapon the Death Star too many
leaks too many leaks in the Empire okay
Death Star and armored space station
with enough power to destroy an entire
planet just like the space force okay
pursued by the Empire's sinister agents
not all bad though a lot of them are
really good guys Princess Leia races
home aboard our starship custodian of
the stolen plans that can save her
people and restore freedom to the galaxy
until Omarosa [ __ ] the whole thing up
there you go
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]